en france 48 heures après la dissolution
conseil des ministres d'unité radicale
la justice prend le relais fermeture du
site internet du groupe d'extrême droite
pour propagande antisémite il mariné et
dominique bonnet méprisable odieux
antisémite
le tribunal de paris n'a pas mâché ses
mots ce matin pour qualifier les textes
diffusés par unité radicale
le groupuscule dispose de deux jours
pour fermer son site une décision
exemplaire selon les parties civiles
on ne pourra plus trouver n'importe quoi
sur internet
ou alors si on trouve quelque chose on a
la possibilité beaucoup plus facilement
de saisir la justice d'intervenir et de
faire cesser ces trous mais unité
radicale a trouvé pense-t-elle une
parade en créant dès aujourd'hui un
autre site qui permet de diffuser les
mêmes idées sous un nom différent pour
les juristes spécialisés cette
provocation pourrait se retourner contre
ses auteurs en incitant les tribunaux à
durcir les peines encourues
manifestement cet incident similaire ou
presque une copie de ce site que l'on
retrouve déjà aujourd'hui dans lequel on
vous dit que c'est bien la succession de
du précédent donc cette résistance va
forcément obligé les parties les
magistrats ou autres à prendre des
décisions complémentaires et je pense
que c'est là qu'on va effectivement
avoir des avancées dans l'internet entre
les formations extrémistes de droite et
les parties civiles l'union des
étudiants juifs de france et
l'association j'accuse le bras de fer
est donc loin d'être terminée ces
groupuscules qui ont déjà gagné une
notoriété inespéré